at the start of the movie we see a house
located in the middle of a forest inside
an eight-year-old boy named Roscoe is
engaged in sketching images of demons
this is because he frequently sees a
demon called dimvos which fascinates him
and inspires his drawings occasionally
dimvos arrives in his bedroom and
watches him draw while also providing
feedback on the artwork however he does
not pose any threat to the boy despite
his demonic nature Roscoe has a best
friend named Eva and they often play
hide and seek together since they are
neighbors their parents are close
friends as well one day as Roscoe is
with his mother he tells her that the
demon visited him once again last night
and they had a good time together
however the mom doesn't take his words
seriously thinking that Roscoe is just
imagining things at night as the boys in
his room drawing devil sketches as usual
he is startled by a loud sound worried
he goes to his parents room to check
only to find out that they have been
burnt to ashes this sends the little boy
into a state of panic and he starts
running around the house out of nowhere
dimvos confronts him and Roscoe demands
an explanation however the demon doesn't
say anything and simply leads the
innocent Roscoe outside the house and
into a mysterious hole the scene then
shifts to 20 years later where some
construction workers are building a
house in the middle of a forest we see
that it's an isolated location with no
settlements nearby at the same time on
the other side of the forest an adult
Roscoe emerges from the cave that he had
entered 20 years ago he then rushes
towards the bushes at Breakneck speed as
if he's running away from something
dangerous after a while he comes across
the location where the construction
employees are working while the workers
are busy with their job Roscoe steals
one of their bags and discovers a pair
of jeans inside he then wears those
jeans and runs back to the place he used
to live which is now completely deserted
he wasn't running away from anything he
just didn't want anyone to see his demon
dog that evening after a day of hard
work the construction workers gather
around to relax and enjoy some drinks
together the group is having a good time
until they are approach by a deadly
demon named ogram the sight sends
shivers down everyone's spines but
before they can even react ogrim lets
out a devilish scream causing all the
workers to collapse in pain following
this ogram approaches a guy and turns
him into a demon using magic he then
instructs the guy to kill all of his
friends obeying the command the man
approaches his own friends and starts
eating them one by one in another part
of the forest as some friends are
enjoying a campfire they are approached
by another frightening demon named
valorga he immediately casts a spell and
hypnotizes everyone present the spell is
so powerful that the Friends start
killing each other mercilessly following
this we see a different demon named role
mortis who arrives at a cemetery he
menacingly starts shouting at the graves
telling them it's time to wake up and
rule the world within a few minutes the
Dead start Awakening and he gathers a
large army of zombies roll mortis then
points them in a specific Direction and
orders them to go there the next morning
we see a grown-up Eva spending some
quality time with her dad at home during
out they are still living near the same
Forest after a while the father gets up
and leaves the house saying he needs to
work in the field however unbeknownst to
him the horde of zombies have surrounded
their house when the father finally
realizes their presence it is too late
as the zombies surround him and brutally
devour him alive in the meantime Eva
hears her father screaming and becomes
startled she rushes outside to
investigate only to see the gruesome
side of her father being dismembered
filled with rage Eva quickly pulls out a
gun and eliminates all the zombies
present however to her horror more
zombies show up and start chasing her
fortunately she manages to get to her
father's car and hastily drives away
from there in the next scene as Roscoe
is strolling around the forest he
stumbles upon Eva's car by chance
recognizing the vehicle he deduces that
the girl is Eva so he calls out her name
the latter is shocked to meet her best
friend after two decades apart and they
celebrate their emotional reunion
briefly after this Roscoe enters Eva's
car and the two of them drive to his old
house once they arrive Eva asks Roscoe
where he had been for the last 20 years
and he begins telling her the story the
scene shifts back to 20 years ago
revealing how a young Roscoe descended
into a mysterious hole after being
summoned by dimvas it turns out the hole
leads to an alternate Dimension known as
the dark womb in other words it's the
place where all demons live dimvos takes
on the role of Roscoe's mentor and
teaches him black magic the little boy
also doesn't object as he considers
dimbos a friend but whenever he talks
about returning home the demon insists
that this is his new home and that
there's nothing for him in the outside
world one day dembos informs Roscoe that
there are many malicious demons in this
realm that intend to harm people and
rule the world he then shows the boy
three jars which imprisoned the three
most fearsome demons ogrim veluga and
real mortis dimvos further reveals that
he is a member of an ancient race of
demons that guards the universe but
since he is getting old he wants Roscoe
to take on his role and become the new
protector of the vessels years passed by
and we see that Roscoe has grown up and
become an adult believing that the boy
is now prepared dembos uses magic and
transmits his powers to him as soon as
Roscoe inherits these Powers he has a
vision of his past where he Witnesses
the tragic death of his parents the
killer was none other than dimvas
enraged Roscoe approaches the demon and
asks why he did all of this in response
stimbus explains that he reluctantly
murdered the parents as that was the
only way to lure Roscoe inside the hole
dimbos explains that after he's gone he
wants Roscoe to take his place and
protect these vessels so that the world
might be saved however Roscoe isn't
convinced by this reasoning and he
angrily declares that he doesn't care
about denvoser's vessels then using his
powers he breaks the vessels releasing
the three dangerous demons as soon as
they break free the first thing they do
is kill DeVos witnessing this Roscoe
becomes scared and realizes that he has
made a big mistake he then rushes out of
the hole and following him the three
demons also also arrive in the forest
back in the present Eva is shocked by
the story and she scolds Roscoe for
causing such havoc and bringing the
demons here she also accuses him of
being responsible for her father's death
and begins hitting him after that she
breaks down in tears remembering her
father and Roscoe consoles her by
claiming that he did not cause this on
purpose in the meantime we see two
Hunters going through the forest in
search of prey one of them suddenly
hears odd noises in the distance and
upon checking he spots the demon valorga
eating a girl falurga also notices the
Hunter and quickly hypnotizes him
following this the hunter who is now
fully controlled by the demon pulls out
his crossbow and mercilessly kills his
friend not far away two girls are seen
passing along the Forest Road unaware
that zombies are following them after a
while they come across the hunter from
earlier wandering in the woods alone
assuming that he needs help and the
girls get out of the car and call out to
him but he suddenly turns around and
shoots one of them with an arrow seeing
this the other girl is horrified and
starts screaming but the hunter shoots
her as well she gets injured in the leg
and cannot walk anymore unfortunately a
group of zombies arrive at the scene and
devour her alive that evening a group of
friends are having a house party when
ogram suddenly appears without wasting
any time he casts a deadly spell on them
causing them to die one after another he
then hypnotizes the girls into being
naked and eventually kills them as well
as all of this is happening Roscoe and
Eva also stumble outside the same house
using his powers Roscoe detects that a
demon is nearby so he cautiously makes
his way to the house when he spots ogre
near the dead bodies Roscoe decides that
it's time to put an end to all of this
so using every last bit of his power he
unleashes a brutal attack on ogram that
eventually kills him elsewhere the other
two demons sent sogram's death and
decide ahead in that direction in the
next scene Roscoe returns home with Eva
only to discover that veluga is already
there the demon strikes Roscoe but our
hero successfully counter-attacks and
injures him however he soon realizes
that it is not vallerga but a regular
guy it is the same construction worker
from earlier in the movie who is
hypnotized by ogram feeling guilty
Roscoe uses his magic to resurrect the
man who soon heals and awakens why
didn't he do that for Eva's dad
following this Roscoe tells the guy that
from now on he must only kill demons and
not regular people the guy obliges
without any hesitation and he rushes to
the cemetery where he eliminates all the
zombies one by one sometime later he
encounters role mortis the leader of the
zombies the guy heroically takes out one
of his horns and also crushes his eyes
after a fierce struggle he eventually
prevails and manages to kill role mortis
that's right a resurrected construction
worker killed one of the most powerful
demons in history the following morning
as Roscoe and Diva are walking through
the forest they come across valorga the
final and the most powerful demon Roscoe
tries to kill him using his best
abilities but the demon is so strong
that he doesn't even budge while Roscoe
chances spells the demon starts laughing
maniacally eventually he unleashes his
powers and finishes off Roscoe and Eva
in an instant in the aftermath falurga
is delighted that he can finally rule
the world now however as he proceeds to
walk away the guy Roscoe had saved
earlier arrives out of nowhere and
attacks him vallerga is badly caught off
guard by this and before he can use his
powers the guy rips out his heart and
kills him once and for all the movie
concludes with the ordinary construction
guys the sole survivor he wanders
through the forest screaming like a
maniac subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching